contingent yeah okay that's why we say
it requires a necessary in existence for
it Sam
makes sense because it could have no
actually no I don't I don't know officer
I don't we come guys before the video
starts miss do check it out it's a
brilliant app for those who want to pray
Salah and share their wards check them
out now that's why I believe everyone is
born a Muslim somebody who submits their
words so baby babies born what do we
mean by that we mean that so that means
that there was University which they
said that I think so this way
[Music]
yeah not in the traditional sense not in
the I wasn't really brought up and I was
brought up in a sort of kind of semi
Christian I'm not really not even
Christian it's difficult to it's boring
never mind but like I'm not most
atheists I find to be quite irritating
really they sort of decide the kind of
blue haired Marxist freaks on campus
just trying to get free speech censored
I don't want to be associated with them
to be honest with you so yeah sure I
think you can be an agnostic am an
atheist to be honest because ones are
claim to knowledge and one is a claim to
belief really everyone's agnostic or
they should say they are because I
cannot think just means you're not
certain so I'm not certain I don't say
there's no God I'm just saying what's it
I don't believe you that there is one
for now that makes it I think I mean I'd
be closed-minded if I said no I'm like
for now thank you
yeah that's what I want to talk to
Muslims okay so last week there was a
group over there I think the Christians
actually know that and they and I had a
poster saying free healing you know kind
of be huge and they quite they claims if
I came over with a broken leg or
something and they uttered a prayer for
me they said I've seen that happen
that's just mended right in front of us
you know we can attested that and they
have some woman who I think was a plant
say oh yes it way it worked for me as
well
right and I obviously didn't have
nothing you know anything wrong with me
but if I had if I say had a broken arm
okay and and they said if we pray to
Jesus or whatever I got it it you know
would be the same if it's of Muslims
although I think it's you guys don't
have the similar healing things as they
do right if that worked
I'm not saying I'd be fully convinced
but that would be a big step you know if
something like that happened if there
was some sort of you know real miracle
that I could see and when I say miracle
I don't mean kind of all just look at
the world around you isn't it beautiful
it must be finely tuned you know if
there was some kind of master physicist
Carl Sagan said extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence so I
don't really know what I could I can't
think of some kind of I in that point
that would be the point that would kind
of push me to believing but it would
have to be something all I know is would
be quite a you know a really good
argument or a really good sort of moment
no
I want to use some arguments and see if
you relate with it okay well because
I've seen many other watches before and
I know from sort of empiricism that you
know watches need a human designer your
watch
personally no yes yes you could say so
then can I say yes belief but not faith
no no it's not the same thing so faith
this is perhaps a more atheistic
definition but I think it is at least
one definition is faith is the belief
without evidence so a belief can
actually have evidence you know you
believe something because it's supports
it whereas faith would be purely but
faith is in epistemological conversation
it's not even blind faith but faith as
an area or what I think is a way of
knowing in fear knowledge or
epistemology is a bit like intuition
it's a sort of knowledge without any
kind of kind of evidence that's grounded
in metaphysical reality or naturalism
so then why we need to say this year you
believe this was the purpose yes okay
yes yes yes yes and a posteriori piece
of knowledge not an a priori knowledge
okay so I know probably cancer no so I
worry about this because I know this is
a priori or analytic knowledge which is
defined by accounts is you know logic
that's yeah it's a logical argument you
know it's it's just it's sort of
self-evident if I say I was it the law
of identity you know all a tree is a
tree that is an a priori bit of
knowledge because you don't need to I
know that without without empiricism
without observation it's innate yes sir
the opposite our April story is
observational empirical okay yes I think
so
[Music]
where did you say the truth not the
truth okay
because the watch is a man-made item and
I don't fit the tree is InterVarsity you
can plant the seed but of course it's a
natural natural occurrence you know so
even if there is a God you know watch
differs from a tree sort of regardless
of whether God is in the picture or not
because you that requires a sort of
direct human action you know effort
together you know a tree something that
we believe God Almighty's created we
ascribe it to Mother Nature random
activities random stuff so what I'm
trying to do with this is that you
understand and acknowledge even though
you did not bow to the country and see
the watch get made innately you know
that it has a purpose it has a design
requires a designer but when we compare
it to the tree I will try to understand
why is it that when it comes to the tree
so when you say innate do you mean a
priori it's not okay so no my knowledge
that that needs a designer is a
posteriori not a priori pick up because
because I've observed Watchers and I've
observed you know people saying look
obviously you know that you need because
I've got a very bitter understanding of
how clocks work because you need a cog
and gears and whatnot you know I know
that we need about it's not innate it's
not something that I was just know yeah
I know you do because if you was walking
yeah yeah yes okay first ariari
posteriori is in posterior meaning
behind it's a mouthful Yeah right
so can I tell you why I think so that's
an argument made by William Paley who
made it before Darwin I know you guys
probably don't believe in evolution but
this was before Darwin came up with his
theory of natural selection and will
impale ease tell me logically the blind
watchmaker book the watchmaker argument
yeah that's that's not a blind
watchmaker as a book driver to Dawkins
but the watchmaker argument is what
you're saying do you know why he's wrong
okay you're saying if you come across a
watch right and say you're part of some
kind of primitive tribe you know you
never had any contact with any sort of
civil you know civilized technologically
advanced peoples okay you're saying if
you encounter to watch having never
encountered a watch or any other kind of
technology before that you would still
innately believe that that had a
designer I disagree with you if you've
had no experience of Technology before I
don't think you can safely say that you
would instantly know that as a designer
do you know what well no no no but you
might think it was naturally occurring
so notice how never mind whatever it's
so created or you know so what are you
doing is your nature yeah we're seeing
what you call nature is God Almighty but
you attribute input
nature because God has his names and
attributes while you're doing it you are
seeing okay that's random events that's
why I'm trying to come to the beginning
I'm just saying finish finish the
universe yeah I'll come to those if you
like but just I'm saying with the what
I'm saying you can't know that maybe
there is some tree on your Island you
haven't explored the islands that
produces these bizarre looking fruits
that looks you know it's got a strap and
it's got numbers and hands that move but
that's not the same as with okay
because with the universe there's a
possibility that it actually did begin
to exist maybe because of God well I'll
go to that in a minute I just want to
address the watch I'm not dodging your
question but but the watch you know okay
it began to exist in the sense that it
was it began when it was pieced together
but the matter that comprises it still
existed before okay so so really you
know the argument you can just trace it
forever back okay but what created that
bit of metal and take it back to the
beginning of the universe and then
you're just talking about the universe
but the watch itself you cannot actually
say for certainty that it's designed if
you've never come across such a sort of
desired technological
but the materials to make it did not
appear from nothing goofy was there from
within yeah it was there from Mother
Nature I just don't think you can say I
think if you were you know like I said
if you've never seen the watch before
and you've never seen you didn't even
know what a kind of clock or any device
was I don't think you would think that's
design I think you would think yeah well
I can't say for certain or maybe if you
were kind of okay so address column or
or contingency when I came here looking
to get an interview with I was er okay I
won't be singing for Mardon I wanted to
ask him a few questions not only about
these arguments but also because I read
his book which I thought was a very
intelligent piece is interesting some
errors I have to say I shook his hand
once but then he got involved in some
fight that was happening elsewhere so
what's with David tomb in his dialogues
concerning natural religion he says he
has this to say on a contingency I don't
fear this is a quote this is my sermon
alysus but who might it is evident that
we can never perceive the non-existence
of a necessary deity as equally
impossible as twice two or two times two
lots of before at least not with our
current faculties is that for me to stop
bit by bit and see says it will still be
possible for us at any time to conceive
the non-existence of what we formerly
conceived to exists I anyone is able to
conceive God's non-existence nor can the
mind ever lie under the necessity of
supposing that any object remain always
in being
same way as we lie under a necessity of
always conceiving two times two two
equal four thus necessary existence has
no real meaning so he questions whether
it's even appropriate to distinguish
between necessary and contingent
contingent existences and then the
character who is using claimed these
goes on to say so that's point number
one point two nine says that's okay
let's assume let's grab the village of
the theists that there is unnecessary
being he says that for all we know the
material world or universe as a whole
itself might be the necessarily existent
being in spite of the way in which parts
of it might depend on other parts since
it must be unknown inconceivable
qualities that make anything a necessary
existent for we know these qualities may
attach to the ordinary physical universe
rather than to any immaterial thing or
person or deity behind its produce maybe
the easier one for you to answer the
necessary necessary being yeah also
necessary existence
you're giving those attributes to the
universe so what you're doing is you're
seeing and this way
all they're doing is that many atheists
exist is that what we do is we get
mother nature so for losing oh this is
mother nature what you're doing is
you're ascribing to be an attribute of
God yeah
the Creator to mother nature's mother
nature of the tree well mother nature
what you just worshipping something
besides I'm not worshiping atly I don't
have anything is that this necessary
existence maybe the universe so what
you've done many other what do you mean
what is that
for example the universe could have been
any other way the Sun isn't gonna be in
there or not be there it could have been
either your shirt could've been there no
it's not necessary it's contingent yes
okay yes it's inside so it could be any
other way yeah yeah the necessary
existence can not be any other way
yeah I gotta go with the argument of the
universe has always been then it's been
crazy and crazy it all goes back to you
it still relies on something that relies
on something else so it's always
contingent yeah okay that's why we say
it requires a necessary in existence for
its M makes sense because they could
have the universe or no access sure okay
well actually no actually no I don't
know officer I would say maybe maybe at
the universe wasn't necessary
but the fact that it is in existence
requires a necessary that's fine let me
show me - I think I do several points
there so what's your first point about
you don't believe in in atheists really
that we we're taking attributes of God
and instead of scrubbing its mother
nature okay right so my disagree with
that is that it's the other way round
for me what you're doing is that
ascribing elements of mother nature to
something and calling it God so it's
actually you who's doing that you know
and I don't believe that's a sin or
anything but I think that's what you're
doing I think that I'm gonna be so bold
as to think that my position is the more
innate one which I'm sure you
disagreement what's and then you said
after that just just rehash your you see
man-made good sounding a bit I think it
could have done but I'm not I'm not sure
I would be justified in saying yes had a
beginning I believe in the Big Bang but
we don't know the Big Bang was the
beginning that
if you walk him down the road and you
see an accident happening yeah yeah you
will say okay yes if you go and go to
the ice cream somebody comes gives you
ice cream
yeah ice cream ice cream yes logically
would deduce in it logically to come to
the best possible understand logically
yes yeah
why is it that when it comes to God when
we say okay hold on a second the
universe
yeah and I'm even using fine-tuning yeah
for example when it comes to the
universe we say oh hold on a second
honey stop there now logic now we're
going into it may have created it so I'm
just wondering well I did make a logical
argument for their for their self
creative it's why you could say I'm not
offended by anything you say that's fine
that's fine but just when I say I made a
logical argument that is a fact now you
could say oh no your logical argument
wasn't valid or it wasn't sounds but my
argument regarding the infinite
causality within the finite time that
was a logical argument by definition so
whatever you say you did not an infinite
number of decimals between 0 and 1 there
are there are an infinite number of
decimals
you know something as far as you know
yeah we're talking certainty what
something has to require equality why is
it that we throw that away
and we'll go with that I believe is an
absurdity possibilities like craziness
so coming from nothing a logical
impossibility it being there for ever
again infinitives in has no beginning
and no end so we cannot have a
subtraction infinite yeah yeah universe
beginning it's the bond so claim of
infinite you can be infinite toward the
future
well not towards apart so Alan Vilenkin
seems to think so yes I do understand
what you're saying you know there will
be no laws to say that's everything
needs a cause because there's no there's
not even any any temporalities that so
there's no effect
there's no nothing
exactly there's no loss yeah
yes I'm seeing that there was nothing
the point that we're seeing is the rock
that our universe exists requires a
pores because if it was nothing you
won't be here when the organism with
occupy therefore that proves to us the
[ __ ] that the universe exists if it does
exist
yeah there is a cause behind it yeah
we believe got to say kun fea Khun P and
it is so good can say I wonder universal
begin he has so great has the power to
make something come from any other way
if it is a necessary existence otherwise
nothing will make sense what you said
these knows every less in place nothing
would make sense the universe either
came look I uh I said you can it come
from nothing impossibility zero our
stone
oh dear Myers so can it create itself
can the universe greater so it's an
impossibility because it has to exist
and believe this at the same time can it
be infinite no we can't because it had a
beginning point and if it doesn't have a
beginning is in heaven and the only
logical rational possibility is yes this
is your place to put our world picture
of what we know at the moment absolutely
with respect no good thing is the moment
we can't have something from as far as
we know but in a hundred years time in
300 years time and a thousand years time
suck that in life we our our knowledge
is expanding understanding we most
suddenly understand things that seem
absolutely impossible at the moment have
you only have to look at you and let's
say I'm Stein the thing is that you know
Einstein talking about a paradigm shift
what Thomas coudn't called a paradigm
shift which is a shift in our
understanding sorry
no one sees this but do you not think
you're doing like a leap of faith what
you've seen is that we made and it might
be a plan I'm sure and maybe do you
think it's because what you do is that
you want to believe that there's not a
god and you seem that I might not know
now but in the future my boy you must be
unfair because then why don't you go
with a certainty that there is an
intelligent being and if in the future
you somehow find food is his paradigm
shift then you can why do we not go with
us which is of origin that there has to
be a creator and then if Sciences
committee guys look man why are we the
Creator is only one option that makes
sense okay I don't even listed some of
the options that make sense so the ex
nihilo model okay the self creative
model to me that is the same sort of you
know line of reasoning as God did it
okay so to me you would need just as
much proof to prove gods as to do so a
purple elephant
yes yes absolutely charter Tommy Tommy
kind of just went with reference to
perhaps one of those options tell me
sort of like in maybe three sentences
something that could be really for
provoking the actor I need to go and
think about to resolve a problem of even
the ex nihilo order self creating
there's no way of knowing and also
whatever happened before the Big Bang
actually has zero influence on what
happened after okay because there was a
breakdown on the quantum level which
would mean there was no enough nothing
happened before the Big Bang maybe it
was God okay would have any influence on
quranic stuff and
[Music]
yeah